so again your alibi is a mysterious
stranger handed you the gun made you put
your prints on it robbed the store and
then hid the gun in your underpants well
yeah if you say it like that it don't
sound believable oh hey captain did you
get my report on the finley murder oh
yeah i looked it over nice work good
thanks dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called captain holt dad he said thanks
dad what no i didn't i said thanks man
do you see me as a father figure peralta
no if anything i see you as a bother
figure cause you're always bothering me
hey
show your father some respect i didn't
call him dad no no no no jacob i take it
as a compliment it's not a big deal i
called vivian mom once and she's my
fiance guys jump on that boyle has
psychosexual issues old news but you
calling holt daddy hey daddy is not on
the table here but you did call him dad
duke you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right i was lying about the hold up but
the dad thing that happened aha
he admitted that his alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my crazy
devious plan i believe you thank you son
you wanna talk about it later over a
game of catch
i'd like that
nutrition bricks sound great
or we could
grab a little street meat kind of a
classic steak out food but whatever
huh
meat
from the street
sounds like a fun treat
i'm a poet
and didn't even know i was rhyming those
words
when you demanded to be put back in the
field i worried that you were being
flippant about your time in prison i
thought you would be reckless but i was
wrong
prison has made you more cautious yeah
but
what if i'm too cautious now i mean i
used to see everything as black and
white and now it's looking real grey to
me
i wish every cop had a voice in their
head asking what if he's innocent you
see it as a weakness but it means you're
growing it makes you a better detective
so you pass your evaluation you can go
back in the field
oh
well
thank you for passing me
but i actually feel like i need a little
bit more time to readjust
i think i should ride the desk for a few
more weeks
i respect that
okay charles you can come hug us now we
know you're still there i never left to
hell
something i'd like to say a pretty
private person so this is kind of hard
for me but
here we go
i'm bisexual all right i will now field
one minute and zero seconds of questions
pertaining to this go amy how long have
you known since seventh grade i was
watching saved by the bell and i thought
zack morris is hot and then i thought
at least a turtle also hot the fact that
the words kelly and kapowski didn't just
come out of your mouth is lunacy what
made you decide to tell us now charles
found out on the road trip and i was
positive he was not gonna be able to
keep the secret for much longer bye rosa
i mean not bye but bye i mean see ya i'm
gonna have fun only having sex with men
just banging dudes left and right i just
stopped saying bye all together so are
you seeing anyone now yeah her name's
tiffany are you lying about her name so
we won't look her up yes i am next do
you know ann hayes i do oh i must say
this is going considerably better than
when i came out to my colleagues they
were not as the kids say awake do you
mean woke i did mean woke but it's
grammatically incoherent if i could have
your attention please
i'm being transferred to the public
relations office i'm leaving the
nine-nine effective immediately what the
hell i don't understand what the hell
why are you doing this what the hell
i want to say
it has been a pleasure to have worked
alongside all of you for the past 21 and
a half months
i'm sorry for getting so emotional
pretty consistent tone actually these
have been the
these have been the best
years of my career oh no this is new
and i know that
every one of you
give me everything you had
and i will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
me more
see
dismissed
sir
i'm coming with you thank you gina i'm
also coming not necessary i must say
this is quite good
is this sauce for your chicken or my
lamb hmm i don't know should we try it
let's whisk it
cold
it's amazing i don't care for it
but i tried
and what a story for kevin
what's going on family game night don't
worry i brought twister
hey hey what was that hey frozen
snacks
you know in another lifetime you and i
would have made a hot ass couple i
agreed
[Music]
yes you should be very proud of yourself
i know things aren't exactly where you
want to be right now but uh i promise
you they will improve thank you captain
every time someone steps up and says who
they are
the world becomes a better more
interesting place
so thank you
i just got word from peralta and boyle
did they make their best they saved the
precinct no they decided to try to bring
in a bigger fish they're not gonna make
the hearing
so jake's doing the right thing instead
of the selfish thing
you did this to him look i know we all
want this precinct to survive but i'm
proud of them
loyalty to your friends and fellow
officers is important but more important
is our loyalty to this city
and its citizens so i guess what i'm
trying to say is
let's go get drunk i want to apologize
for yesterday inserting myself into my
employee's breakup with my nephew
somehow
uh backfired that's nerdfold i'm the one
that made us seem like a dumb crying
baby
i'm considering having my tear ducts
melted shut it's not the end of the
world to feel
things i guess not
it's up there
the thing is i really cared about marcus
but he wanted to get married and
i'm just not ready for that and if i'm
not ready with a guy as great as marcus
then
what if i'm never ready what if that was
it my one chance of love
and what if i never get a second chance
i don't know
i'm just
just sad
well i i understand
it must be very difficult
wait are you crying
yes
thank you for acknowledging my feelings
thank you for acknowledging my
we're both great at this
santiago
precinct's been saved why are you so
glum because our mentorship is over i
blew it all in one day yes vol one of
our mentorship
there's more volumes of course you think
i could fit it all in one binder
okay
okay
you don't seem very excited oh i was
just adhering to section 7 page 145 no
emotional displays in the workplace
excellent i taught you well now if
you'll excuse me um i have some work to
do
on the roof
if you really think it's necessary i
will establish a social media presence
but i'll be setting up my own account
and i assure you i won't be resorting to
foolish gimmicks involving my dog uh you
might want to rethink that stance
because how cute would cheddar look in
his hat please when it comes to clothes
cheddar wears little booties in the snow
or cheddar wears nothing diaz i want to
apologize
i'm not talking to you
oh oh it worked the pegging worked what
no here we go
oh
gotcha you're never going to catch me oh
yeah
yeah
yes i did it and hitchhike's gonna lose
rosa and holtz are gonna beat him rosa
stop i give up i want you to know i'm
sorry for prying win this thing and
enjoy your day off and if you ever want
a friend to sit with you and silently
listen to death metal just know i'm
always here
okay
i'd like that
what no what are you freaks doing we're
leaving the competition some things are
more important than a game no they're
not
you like it not at all you can leave a
lot of changes
you